[Music]
ah
a witch hunt humans are tireless in
their pursuit of reason
it's 1950. following threats from the
communist governments
of the soviet union and china
anti-communist sentiment in the united
states
is at an all-time high senator joseph
mccarthy claims
he has a list of 205 communists in the
u.s
who are influencing government policy
didn't i just change the channel
ah i see it's a different witch hunt
the senate forms a committee to
investigate mccarthy's claims
mccarthy names his first case against
prominent lawyer
judge and activist dorothy kenyon
he accuses her of membership to 28
organizations that are communist fronts
newspapers around the country rush to
her defense pointing out her vocally
anti-communist record the senate
committee schedules a hearing
anyway and she has just five days to
prepare
this is too much if the government won't
be a voice of reason
i'll have to
that's better i'm surprised you good
legislators have agreed to move this
hearing forward
you're falling prey to a type of
argument from ignorance
assuming that a claim is true because it
hasn't been proven
false the claim being senator mccarthy's
accusations against
judge kenyon for which he provided no
legitimate evidence is that right
i thought so some of the so-called
communist organizations he accused her
of joining
don't even exist to assume a claim is
true because it hasn't been proven false
ignores many other possibilities that it
hasn't been proven false
yet that it can't be proven true or
false
or that it isn't completely true or
completely false
to name few this leads to a handy rule
of thumb
a burden of proof lies with the person
making the claim
in other words you make the claim you
supply the proof
if someone told you aliens exist would
you head off to find
proof that they don't exist of course
not
you tell that person to show you the ufo
the same applies when someone makes a
claim that contradicts an established
consensus
so when all the available evidence
suggests that humans are causing an
increase in global temperatures the
burden of proof has been fulfilled
if you disagree it becomes your
responsibility
to prove otherwise right
i've gotten ahead of myself you'll see
what i mean soon enough
anyway your legal system supposedly
recognizes this rule
so what are you all doing here
[Music]
it's july 17 1950 and the senate
subcommittee has officially dismissed
all charges against
kenya as they should it's 1954
and the senate has formally disciplined
mccarthy
took them long enough he will serve out
the rest of his term but will never
again be elected to a public office
because of his widespread anti-communist
influence
hundreds of people have been
incarcerated and thousands have lost
their jobs
look what the communists did
feeling smart are we all right let's see
if you can outsmart the fallacy that
fooled a generation of doctors
with this video